bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj e ad oggi sono
tornati sul cazzo il muletto
cioè ho scoperto perché il fatto che ho
trovato delle nord fighissime di gozzi
muletto che poi vi farò vedere magari
nei prossimi episodi ho scoperto che
private o riuscita a sbloccare dove
cazzo ecco questa paul booth per la
mente il poggio che a ragazzi muletto
perché lo sbloccata subito cioè vi
rendete conto come cazzo
ecco perché questa è la fisica li sto
gioco ragazzi mi sorprende ecco le due
show caso non vi capita mai di girare
per la città e vedervi una giraffa che
vi arriva intestano perché normale var
amico mio io ti dirò una cosa turista e
sul cazzo fai allora sai cosa devi fare
devi buttarmi lo zoccolo l'ho mancato
tuo solito mancato non era mia
intenzione li facciamo allora di vip
armi
lo zoccolo eccolo lì perfetto finto
sull'albero dove andare ragazzi l'ho
perso dove cazzo andato a finire lega io
ve lo dico non ho mai visto una giraffa
volare in questo modo splendido però
questa al suo stile questo non c'è
dubbio sento potente costa giraffa
enorme bellezza cazzo non volevo far
sono finito su un albero a caso ragazzi
di raccomandano domani guardate tutti
gli alberi che se ci vedete giraffa
appoggiate sopra sapete perché si fa
salire una cazzo di scala con una
giraffa enorme spiegatemelo voi ma possa
arrivare alla fine madonna madonna v6
tempi vico in una maniera incredibile
poiché fermi lo sto facendo
perché sono i maschi incastrato merda a
non posso salire 41 che discriminazione
per le giraffe e allora io scendo di
quel perché mi sento figo ok che botta
ragazzi mi sento potente non mi sono mai
sentito così tu non puoi passare
maledetta tu puoi madonna che esagerato
cazzo ma se io le classi la macchina
quella che dice
ci riesco se ragazzi son riuscita a
leccare la macchina con la cina pasta
cosa è e memorabile il prezzo se per
caso andate in giro e vi vedete una
giraffa divine call auto sapete che è
normale ma ragazzi ma se c'è tipo la la
la la gara di sumo con con la girata è
possibile io faccio ma affanculo il
primo round lo ha vinto sono un fenomeno
con la giraffa e troppo facile
sono troppo forte dove cazzo lo spirito
quelli in afghanistan
[Applauso]
ultimo round riga ce la posso fare
[ __ ] dove lo per non lo prendo si
no non esce pezzo di merda io ho un
umano onu ma non a scagliarsi contro
brutto stronzo le vittoria devi morire
si no eccola è ancora dentro le cose che
non muore sto bastardo senza ho fatto io
cosa cazzo sono diventato qualcuno mi
spiega cosa cazzo è sta roba sono
diventate una capra con la lingua di
fuori un po allungata e la cosa non è
normale ma sono fortissimo adesso marche
bello che sia tipo calcio le persone
adesso finiscono nello spazio ovvero
letteralmente si sono ragazzi tu che
cazzo ci fai qui [ __ ] ragazzi è la
cosa più oscena che abbia mai visto in
vita mia cena cosa inguardabile che
rimpiazzerà e john the grudge e con
questo museo pecci paz successo ragazzi
sono finito nello spazio non credi non
chiedetemi come tratto c'è il buco li
cesca centrarlo sono un fenomeno sono
quasi e se io vado qua dentro cosa al
caso mi trasformo ho paura di vederlo a
sto punto perché non lo so oddio lunga
vita al re supremo delle capriate
letteralmente ragazzi questa sarebbe una
sarebbe un kamikaze
tu non puoi passare ma sei mas pronto
anche adesso però io sono al dio supremo
delle capre non puoi trattarmi così
maledizione è una cosa è ma perché
ditemi perché perché è una cosa che cosa
cosa fai
cosa fa fa tutto lei va facendo tutto
lei regali non sto facendo niente non è
normale qui la festa
ragazzi ho saputo che qua c'è del mancio
da mangiare perché io ho fame o come di
esseri umani con il mercato è finito
non voglio neanche saperlo voglio
provare ragazzi a portare cinque persone
qui per vedere se riesce a trasformarmi
in una giraffa satanica che sarebbe il
colmo praticamente
[Musica]
siamo ragazzi un po paura di vedere che
cazzo va succedere perché non lo so però
minchia ok allora dovrebbero ci siamo ci
siamo ragazzi fermi fermi quando è
diventato la giraffa satanica si può
diventare giraffe satanica che figo è
una cosa che finché è bellissimo [ __ ]
sì ma che perfetto adesso sì che è il
massimo del sexy buongiorno saltano
senta io ho bisogno di sapere un
attimino come funziona sta cosa perché
sonora capra ok merda merda ragazzi
aiuto l'istat precisa ok sono vivo sono
vivo per miracolo
ragazzi mi è finita la testa nel trita
nel pezzo succede agli orto mista
triturando un coso ma io sono ancora
vivo misticamente buon giochi che cazzo
ti balle guarda che non è gratis me lo
fai il giro è brutto stronzo
eccolo lì perfetto ragazzi si vendono
bistecche di giraffa alta magra satanica
su ebay
no no ecco lo sapevo il jazz cazzo video
oggetto che ecco la lega ce l'abbiamo
anche il jazz che come se non bastasse
ragazzi anche se so che non lo
raggiungerò mai il mio obiettivo è il
deltaplano maledizione non ce la farò
non è impossibile è assurdo si no
regali cazzo cazzo [ __ ] fin qua fin
qua chiunque si no cazzo cero classiche
cazzo si novas incazzato non lo prenderò
mai lo stesso 15 posso provare quanto
voglio ragazzi è la prima volta che
potrete vedere una giraffa così sexy
scendere uno scivolo del genere però è
una cosa che capita una volta nella vita
ragazzi pakula per caso voglia di
aiutare una capra incastrata
ma porca [ __ ] come ci sono finito qui
perfetta
[Musica]
ce l'ho fatta
i ragazzi ci ho fatto il mio mi chiedete
come non mi chiedete fottutamente come
la mia vita è completa da adesso in
avanti e non ci credo non è possibile
non ci crederò mai non ci crederò
fottutamente mai ma sentivo le cassi la
macchina mentre passa non ce l'ho fatta
a il camion incameri camera
il camion si ama buongiorno e la
giornata vero senza ne dispiace se entro
i cap
ok è la madonna c'è accoglienza si
stende propri ma se io la leggo da fuori
la prende non penso però di due la presa
ragazzi posso leccargli le tette
resta il più bel giorno della mia vita
il quale care dove cazzo è finita la mia
testa
qui se ti sei prega 6 pregata di darmi
la mia testa maledizione
eccolo lì perfetto ma se tipo entrassi
in casa a minchia non si può entrare in
casa ah sì si può si può non si può far
manco io entro lo stesso perché solo
cazzo siamo siamo dentro casa con una
giraffa anche se non ci sto non sono
anche come ho fatto a entrare ma non
importa
[ __ ] che cazzo successo tempi eri
tu rimani attaccato qui ok io vedo che
cazzo riesco a fare per uscire dalla
fiat
oddio ragazzi invochiamo satana in
persona che non sa neanche come ce l'ho
fatta ma non importa va bene ragazzi
direi che posso concludere qui perché ho
fatto disastri su disastri costa giraffa
ascolta capra alta scusate al cloud che
volevo farmi sapere che ci sono un
miliardo di altre cose che posso ancora
provarci non avete idea di quanta ce ne
sono perché c'è con le mode è diventata
infinito sto gioco poi vedrete che vi
assicuro soltanto che non avete visto
niente ancora perché non vi spoiler o
nulla ma vedrete nei prossimi comunque
ragazzi concluso più l'episodio mentre
la capra alta continua a girare quindi
come al solito ragazzi 6 video è
piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook e come non
divido flat nella descrizione tennis da
prestiti iscrivetevi in dieci di mediano
prossimo video
dai ragazzi